At this point, we've defined a bipartite
graph and the notion of a matching.
Now we're going to see
the connection with maximum flow.
Intuitively, a maximum matching problem
should feel like we're trying to push
as much stuff from one side of
the partition to the other.
It should be no surprise, then, that
there turns out to be an easy reduction
to the maximum flow problem,
which we've already studied.
We build a flow network that
has the same set of vertices,
plus two more which serve
as the source and the sink.
We then add edges from the source
to one-half the partition, and
from the other half
the partition to the sink.
Internal edges are given a direction
from the source side to the sink side.
All capacities are set to 1.
Setting the capacities of the new
edges to 1 is important to insure that
flow from or
to any vertex isn't more than 1.
We only want to match each
of these vertices once.
Having constructed the graph,
we run Ford-Fulkerson on it.
And we return the edges with
positive flows as the matching.
Actually, all edges will have
flows zero or one, as we'll see.
The time analysis here is rather simple.
Building the network is order E, or
maybe order V depending on
the representation used.
In any case, this is small,
however, compared to the cost of running
Ford-Fulkerson, which is E times V.
Note that V is a bound on the total
capacity of the flow, and
hence a bound on the total
number of iterations.
In this particular case,
this bound gives a better one
than we would obtain either by the
scaling algorithm or by Edmonds-Karp.
Lastly, of course,
we have the step of simply returning
the edges with positive flows, and
that's just a matter of writing
the answer out, so that's order V.
Clearly, Ford-Fulkerson
is the dominant part, and
we end up with an algorithm
that is order E times V.